Welcome back to another episode
of the Wine Down.
Woo!
We are pleased
to have our special guest,
Jay Ellis,
who's famously known
for his character, Lawrence.
Who will be joining us
in unpacking "Lowkey Happy."
-Yeah.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
ISSA RAE: This was
a big episode.
PRENTICE PENNY:
It was a big episode.
-It went down.
(ALL LAUGHING)
Issa and Lawrence have been
through a lot this series.
-JAY ELLIS: Mm-hmm.
-Why do you think
this was the right time
for them to unpack
their relationship?
It just feels like now
they've both kind
of gotten through that moment,
and can really have
an honest conversation
with each other
in a way that they never
have before.
Where like there's no blame,
there's no
"your fault, my fault."
You know what I mean?
Yeah, I also think
Condola's question helped.
Sometimes you don't think
about the what if,
or-- I think that him
being posed that question...
-ELLIS: Yeah.
-...forced him
to think about things
in a new light.
And the bravery
to have him call her
and try to discuss it
with her,
to see what's up. "What did--
Where did I go wrong?"
Or, "Did I give up too easily?"
You know, women can usually--
like, will forgive more,
in a certain way.
We talked about in the room,
of like the reverse of that,
men having a harder time
with a woman who cheats
on them,
and you want
to unpack that for Lawrence.
And is it just gonna be my pride
that gets in the way of this?
Or what did I do wrong
to contribute to that?
Then maybe let me unpack it,
and maybe my feelings
aren't fully over.
Nothing,
he did absolutely nothing.
(BOTH LAUGHING)
-He did nothing to contribute.
-Wow.
There were lines that you said
in the episode
-that say differently, so...
-Y'all wrote it, so...
Oh, so you have to say it?
So you don't believe--
Great acting, son.
So the sit-down dinner scene,
what do you think they realize
about each other,
after having that discussion?
Well there's so many new truths.
I mean, for Issa
to find out that Lawrence
was so deep in doubt
and insecurities,
and depression,
that he wanted to leave
and go home,
and he was kind of staying
because he didn't want
to let her down.
You know, I think she thinks
that she was supportive,
but didn't know how
-to be supportive.
-I think, for me,
it's that dagger moment,
when Issa says,
that sometimes she used
to just drive around
because she didn't want
to come home.
Oh, man,
that was heartbreaking.
Don't nobody ever want
to hear that.
-Hmm.
-Like processing hearing that
for the first time.
For me, it's this moment
where Lawrence goes, like,
"Oh, shit, I put up this wall."
-PENNY: Yeah.
-That was so big.
PENNY: Yeah.
What I liked about this
was it was sharing things
about each other
that neither the other knew.
"Maybe I bought a ring,"
"I used to drive around."
Like, "I wanted to move home,
but I didn't tell you."
You know what I mean?
Like all these types
of things,
of like, "I didn't feel
like you wanted to touch me."
Like there's so much there
that's like,
"Oh, we were holding
all this in,
that maybe had we shared
some of these things--"
Like why you say,
"Why didn't you tell me?"
It's like, it's hard
to say those things.
I mean, you both could've said
those things to each other.
That was
the biggest realization
is that they weren't talking,
you know?
Condola was like a little mad
in this episode, to me, um...
She just kept on...
-...appearing, yeah.
-(MIMICS WHISPERING)
It's just like,
you know every single time
we got deeper and deeper,
here she comes.
What do you think about
the way that Lawrence
was responding
to Condola's texts and calls?
Uh, it reminds me
of those moments
where it's like,
you're trying
to do the right thing,
or the thing that feels,
at least, good in the moment.
But, like,
-something kind of keeps, like--
-Mm-hmm.
It's like that Michael Corleone
line,
it's like as soon
as you get out,
they pull you right back in.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it almost reminded me
of that.
But I think, for him,
I think it was a reminder
that like, A,
there was something
that needed to be finished
there.
But, then, B, also,
he was not going to let
the conversations,
and the texts from Condola
stop the moment
that he was having with Issa.
'Cause he, A, may never
get this moment again.
And, B, this is the first time
that the two of them
have been in a space
where they could be vulnerable.
But also be, just kind of,
carefree with each other
and just be relaxed around
each other.
I mean that moment,
Lawrence was gonna let Issa go.
Issa, having to, at the end,
kind of step up
and decide, like,
"We're never gonna get
this moment again.
If I walk out this door,
I will not be a part
of his tomorrow, Condola might.
He might go over there
and rekindle something,
so this is my only chance."
I say that as soon as Lawrence
invited Issa into the apartment,
and asked to go to the bathroom,
I for sure think that Issa
went in the mirror.
-And had a rap?
-And had a rap.
That was for sure
what she did.
-What about that couch?
-It feels to me like, uh,
when you got a real one,
don't let 'em go.
-(CHUCKLES)
-That's how it feel to you?
Yeah, Lawrence hot.
I'm just saying.
You slipped it,
you thought it was--
-You thought it was--
-Yeah, exactly.
That was about yourself.
So obviously, um, at the end
of the night,
-y'all do the nasty.
-(ALL LAUGHING)
I remember in the script
it says, "Make L.O.V.E."
(ELLIS LAUGHING)
Um... But is there hope
for Issa and Lawrence?
At the end of this episode,
to me, what we see,
is like two people
who are fully accepting
-of each other for who they are.
-Yeah.
And Issa-- Issa walking home
at the end of the episode,
kind of just satisfied
with what happened.
And I think that satisfaction
goes either way.
Like I can walk away from him
and feel like, "Okay,
I got all the answers
I needed."
Or, "I'm ready to explore
something down the line."
So, we gotta watch and see
which one it is.
Yeah, right?
So thank you again
for joining us
for another episode
of the Wine Down.
We can't wait for you
-to join us again next week.
-ISSA: Woo!
-Cheers, y'all.
-Two more!
Cheers! Two more episodes!
-What's gonna happen?
-I don't know.
-Well, we know, but...
-(ALL LAUGHING)
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪